let me be clear
the evacuation of thousands of people
from kambo
is going to be hard and painful no
matter when it started when we began
there is no way to evacuate this many
people without pain and loss of
heartbreaking images you see on
television but we have a long way to go
and a lot could still go wrong
a lot can still go wrong indeed
president biden talking yesterday about
the chaos in afghanistan he says the u.s
could extend the august 31st deadline to
get everyone out safely but the taliban
is drawing a red line over that warning
there will be consequences if he delays
withdraw beyond that date and fox news
learning of an internal intelligence
report warning the u.s that isis and al
qaeda plan to begin pressuring american
forces to leave before the president's
deadline by launching attacks on the
airport the white house asked today
about the threat al qaeda poses
so friday the president said that we got
rid of al qaeda in afghanistan
sunday the secretary of state said there
is al qaeda in afghanistan so
are you presenting the president with
the full picture or is he just
misapplying the intelligence when he
makes these public statements
the president was referring to al
qaeda's capability to attack the united
states which the intelligence community
tells us today
is not present in afghanistan what is
president in afghanistan right now to
our forces at the airport is a serious
threat from isis k which we're trying to
deal with and of course there's the
possibility that al qaeda could
reconstitute an external plotting
capability in afghanistan
there's just one other exchange we want
to show you and this was between peter
ducey asking the white house press
secretary about americans
and being stranded in afghanistan
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home one of the things
jesse that happened uh over the week
friday and over the weekend is that
president biden would say something but
then you would look at your screen and
you're like well that's exactly not what
we're hearing and in fact even this
morning on newsroom we talked to
um
a man who they're america they are
afghani originally but they became
american citizens but his wife is stuck
there and stranded and we talked to him
and they're distressed because they
can't get through to the state
department stranded means dana if you
want to leave somewhere and you can't
that's the definition of stranded do you
think americans can just go to kabul
airport and take up on the next flight
they can't so they're stranded so i
don't even know why she's arguing about
that word it reminds me of it's not a
crisis at the border it's a challenge
that's what they're doing they're
worried about messaging all right so
at first it was
things are going great and now it's it
was always going to be a mess or oh we
planned for this and then oh no one
could have planned for this or people
are clinging from the wings of airplanes
and oh that was four days ago now it's
all my heart breaks for these people hey
get to the airport and you'll get out as
soon as you can no no actually no
don't go to the airport now elevated
terror threatener now it's we're going
to get out by september 11th and now no
no no we're going to have to possibly
stay past september 11th and now it's a
game of chicken with the taliban taliban
has a deal after september 11th deals
off so you're going to get into an
actual
right actual hostage crisis with live
rounds we don't know what the taliban's
capable of we've seen the reports from
the airport
20 casualties firing bullets into a
crowd
women getting their teeth knocked out
babies getting trampled to death
american passports getting torn up like
that americans being beaten
so right now taliban is basically the
gate agent we had to go to the taliban
here's my passport up either they rip it
up or they ask for a bribe up you don't
have any money aka to the kneecap up
maybe you'll come up with some money
tomorrow that's how it is you can't have
a plan like this where you're at the
mercy of a terrorist organization biden
stranded americans in a war zone then
tried to go back on vacation dana could
you imagine any other president that
tried to pull that off created a
humanitarian crisis arm the enemy then
tried to go back on vacation he sold us
as he was the guy that was compassionate
and competent he hasn't shown either
jessica what about that criticism in
some of the polls over the weekend that
showed that he has taken a dip on
approval in lots of different areas but
that there is bipartisan disapproval
about how this was handled
i think that it's serious for the
administration and you've seen the
number of briefings has increased
tenfold right from where we were last
week where we were saying like when are
we going to hear from someone and now we
have multiple per day jake sullivan ned
price out there jensaki's back at the
podium every day the president spoke
twice i believe over the weekend he also
had a hurricane uh to deal with so they
obviously know it's incredibly serious
uh the polling it seems like took the
biggest hit because of the covet
response which is i know something that
we'll talk about later in the show as
well it's a huge crisis on his plate um
but the dichotomy between you know what
you're hearing in the images is
something that's really hard to take
especially when you see a two-year-old
trampled right like those are things
that you can't unsee
in your life and i think that
what we've been noticing or at least
what i've been noticing is the shift to
focusing on how we're going to get these
people out and that august 31st deadline
because we're not negotiating with a
normal government we're negotiating with
a bunch of terrorists who now run a
country
and august 31st if they even hold to
that is only eight days away so it'll be
interesting to see what comes out of the
g7 meeting tomorrow the boris johnson is
convening if they have a plan because it
seems like the brits have actually been
making a good amount of progress
yeah and it feels like the brits are not
leading from behind in this situation um
i also wanted to play this for you this
is the about isis uh there in the
control room if you could pull this one
up tyrus president biden says he
understands the threat of isis k uh take
a look at this
we're maintaining the constant business
to monitor
and disrupt threats from any source
including the likely source being isis
but we're under no illusions about the
threat even though we're moving back the
perimeter
significantly
we're working hard and as fast as we can
to get people out
that's our mission the perimeter issue
has been back and forth and disputed as
well tyrus but i think that many
americans might be surprised to hear
that the threat of isis still exists
well the optics is what we're seeing in
optics and jesse you're so right they
they're trying to paint the picture that
they're doing everything by the book and
that bad things were gonna happen the
simplest thing was is that before you
pull the troops out you get the other
people out i mean neither one of us are
military guys and it made perfect sense
to us but now what we're seeing is
they're the optics of you they're not
gonna say it's it is the taliban that's
doing this now we're going to hear well
we didn't know that isis was going to
come back and al-qaeda's come back
because the taliban in itself when they
talk to the government if this is not a
unified group they are basically
tribes of different little warlords who
do different things they have no control
over what their soldiers do on the field
to civilians we're seeing that and when
they tell me to go to the airport it's
literally now what mob can get through
fastest they bummer us thing they're not
even getting a chance to vet people and
things like that because they're
literally climbing over the walls why
because they're getting shot in the
streets they're the women are getting
beat up like there is
nothing about what he's talking about
matches what we are seeing on the ground
and once again it's going to be the
boots not the suits that that save the
day
um
kenny you can talk about whatever you
want but i do just want to play this as
well just about isis and al qaeda watch
this exchange between chris wallace on
fox news sunday and the secretary of
state
is al-qaeda gone from pakistan uh from
afghanistan al-qaeda's capacity to do
what it did on 9 11 to attack us to
attack our partners or allies
from afghanistan is vastly vastly
diminished
is it gone
are there are there al qaeda
members and and remnants in afghanistan
yes
so there's the handling of the
evacuation but then there's the then
what do we do now to keep everyone safe
and it's then what do we do now which is
going to only compound and get worse and
worse and worse which only makes it more
dangerous for the americans who are
stranded there they are stranded that
requires a sense of urgency and you're
not necessarily getting that because
you're hearing one thing from the
intelligence community and you know
people at the defense department you're
hearing something completely different
and a very defensive posture from the
president you're not hearing anything
from the vice president
on this but you know if i had a family
member or a good friend or someone who
would put their life on the line to
translate for me or to help me out while
i would while i was doing a tour in
afghanistan and they were being left
there and the press secretary is saying
how dare you that's irresponsible to use
the word stranded those are the words
that we should be using because it's her
boss who is sending people to die and
it's you know it's the boots who are
being sent into a situation that is
growing worse and worse by the day by
the suits and they don't have an answer
for it and i don't trust their
intelligence when they say you know oh
yeah you know al-qaeda's all gone how do
you know that i don't trust you know
that because if you knew that if you
knew exactly what you were dealing with
we wouldn't have this right now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else